par un beau matin de mars les se rend
dans son hypermarché ce qui est comme un
marché mais en dimension supérieure à 3
sur les étalages de délicieuses hyper
fruits de saison sont en promo d hyper
citron des hyper kiwi et même des hyper
pamplemousse il est alors attiré par de
superbes hyper orange en promo à
seulement 95 centièmes l'hyper kg une
affaire incroyable mais un si bas prix
ça cache forcément quelque chose et les
petites lignes lui confirme la
supercherie c'est hyper orange
appartiennent à un espace de dimension
1000 wii parce que dans une hyper orange
de très grande dimension
l'essentiel du poids se trouve dans la
peau une des nombreuses bizarreries des
espaces à très grandes dimensions et ça
tombe bien j'ai un épisode avec les pour
en parler
les espaces de très grande dimension
c'est vraiment le quotidien d'un
chercheur en informatique théorique et
en particulier en machine learning
oui parce que les points de ces espaces
correspondent à des listes de nombre et
parce que les listes de nombres encode
toutes sortes d'objets d'études du
machine learning que ce soit du texte
des images ou des vidéos et bien souvent
chaque document correspond à une liste
particulièrement longue de tel nombre
autrement dit chaque document numérisé
est un point dans un espace de très
grandes dimensions et permettre aux
intelligences artificielles de bien
analyser des documents numérisés
ça revient leur fournir les outils
nécessaires pour bien disséqué et
exploiter les structures géométriques de
ces espaces de très grande dimension
revenons aux bases c'est quoi un carré
ou plutôt comment peut-on dessinée dans
un plan à deux dimensions
un carré une méthode que l'on peut
mettre en place et de considérer les
points dont les coordonnées ne s'écrive
qu'avec les nombreux - 1 et 1
il ne reste qu'à relier deux ados les
points mais seulement ceux dont les
coordonnées de 10 faire que sur une
seule coordonner ce qui est bien avec
cette procédure c'est qu'elle permet de
dessiner un carré dans un espace à deux
dimensions mais elle décidera aussi un
cube dans un espace à trois dimensions
et en généralisant des espaces de
dimensions plus grandes on obtiendra
alors des hypercube de même on peut
aisément généraliser la notion de cercle
ou de disques un cercle de rayon 1
c'est l'ensemble des points dont la
distance au centre est égal à 1 et le
disque c'est ce qu'on obtient quand on
remplace l'égalité par une inégalité en
dimension 3 on obtient alors la sphère
et la boule unités et bien en dimensions
supérieures ou n'obtient de même ni
r ce faire et l'hyper bull une idée bref
on a des objets géométriques qui se
généralise parfaitement aux dimensions
supérieures leurs propriétés comme leur
volume par exemple se généralise elle
aussi mais apportent leur lot de
phénomènes contre intuitif avant de
parler du problème de la peau des hyper
orange
commençons avec le paradoxe des hyper
sphère inscrits prenons un carré est un
disque inscrits dans ce carré quelle
proportion du carré est recouvert par le
disque avec 2,3 calcul on trouve que le
disque représente 78 5% du carré à
présent faisons la même chose mais en
dimension 3 avec une sphère inscrits
dans une boule quelle proportion du cube
sera représenté par cette boule
là encore avec quelques calculs on peut
montrer que cette proportion est de 52
4%
oui mais ce qui est bizarre c'est ce qui
va se passer quand on généralise cette
construction aux dimensions supérieures
je vous invite d'ailleurs à mettre pause
pour y réfléchir à quoi ressemble une
hyper sphère inscrits dans un hyper cube
la réponse c'est à pas grand chose
ou plus précisément l'hyper sphère de
représente rapidement qu'une proportion
infime de l'hyper cube et ça même si
elle touche toutes les surfaces de
l'hyper cube
à titre d'exemple l'hyper boules de
dimension 6 représente moins de 10% de
l'hyper cube qui la contient et cela
descend à moins de 1 % en dimensions 9
pour comprendre cela on peut faire la
remarque suivante disons que l'hyper
cube et l'hyper sphères sont centrés sur
l'origine et que le rayon de l'hyper
super est égal à 1 et tirons un point au
hasard dans hypercube ça correspond à
tirer les coordonnées indépendamment
entre -1 et 1 en moyenne chaque
coordonnées de ce point va avoir une
valeur absolue autour de 1,2 me met
alors en dimensions d d'après le
théorème de pythagore qui lui se
généralise bien assez grande dimension
la distance entre un point typique de
l'hyper cube est l'origine sera
d'environ racine carrée de 1/2 au carré
pu s'amener au carré puis cinq mille
carré etc soit racine carrée 2d sur deux
or pour qu'un point soit à l'intérieur
de l'hyper ce faire on a vu qu'il devait
être à une distance inférieure à 1 de
l'origine on en vient à la conclusion
qu'un point dans l'hyper ce père est
nécessairement un point très atypique de
l'hyper cubes ce qui revient à dire que
très rares sont les points de l'hyper
cube qui sont à l'intérieur de l'hyper
ce faire ou dit de façon équivalente
l'hyper bull inscrits dans l'hyper cube
n'est pas grand chose comparé à l'hyper
cube
en fait c'est encore plus étrange que
cela même comparé à rien du tout une
hyper bull c'est plutôt quelque chose de
pas très grand si elle a un très grand
rayon l'hyper volume sera ridiculement
petit dès que les espaces auront
beaucoup dimensions et ça ça peut se
calculer plus précisément on peut
calculer par récurrence l'hyper volume
d'une hyper boules de rayon air est de
dimension des en multipliant par to her
carrés sur des celui de dimension des -2
ainsi même si on prend des hyperboles de
rayon 300 lorsqu'on considère des
espaces de dimension d'un million le
volume de ces hyper bull sera de l'ordre
de r puissance 2 millions / 1 million
factorielle ce qui fait environ 10
puissance moins 100000 autrement dit en
dimensions 2 millions l'hyper cubes de
côté 1 et plus d'un google deux fois
plus grand que l'hyper poule de riom 300
intuitivement ça veut dire que si vous
prenez un point au hasard dans un espace
de dimension 2 millions il sera très
improbable que vous tombiez à une
distance de moins de 300 d'un point que
vous cherchez à atteindre
tout se passe comme si tous les points
des espaces de grandes dimensions
étaient tous très éloignés les uns des
autres
autant dire que pour l'algorithme du
plus proche voisin dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode 9 ans grande dimension c'est
carrément morts
revenons-en plutôt à notre hyper aux
roches de dimension mille le vendeur
n'est pas du genre à se moquer de ses
clients
cette orange à un volume comparable à
celui dernier perd apéro cubes d'un
mètre de côté
autrement dit sans veillon mesure
environ 7 mètres peut avoir du mal à
faire rentrer ça dans mon hyper sac mais
elle devra pouvoir transporter ça oui
mais est-ce que ça vaut le coup
imaginons que l'épaisseur de la peau de
l'hyper orange représente 1% de son
rayon une peau particulièrement fine
donc la partie mangeable du luberon
rouge représente donc 99% du rayon le
hic c'est que cette partie mangeable
représentent une proportion de 99 %
puissance 1000 de tout l'hyper orange et
ça ça corresponde à peine 1 23 millièmes
autrement dit malgré la finesse de la
peau 99.9 195% de l'hyper orange sera
épluché de façon plus générale en
dimensions des si on considère de boules
concentriques tels que la boule
l'intérieur un rayon qui est une
fraction air du rayon de la boule
extérieur alors la boule intérieure aura
un volume qui est une proportion air
puissance des du volume de la boue
extérieur et en grande dimension ça fait
des différences énormes
bref c'est hyper orange c'est bien une
supercherie voir une hyper jury enfin
même si tu ne comptes pas les manger
je te conseille d'aller visiter l'hyper
planète qui produit ses hypers orange
c'est une planète incroyable une hyper
bull d'à peine 1 km de rayon mais elle
est de dimension mille de façon étrange
presque tous les points de cette hyper
planète sont juste à côté de son hyper
équateur et oui ça c'est fou pour une
hyper planète de rayons un kilomètre
l'inégalité iso périmétrique montre
justement que la distance typique entre
un hyper équateur et un point de l'hyper
bull pris au hasard est de l'ordre de 1
/ racine carrée de des kilomètres en
dimensions 1000
ça fait trente mètres seulement
étrangement tout point de l'hyper
planète de rayon d'un kilomètre est à
seulement quelques dizaines de mètres de
l'hyper equateur quelle que soit cette
hyper équateur et le cas des dimensions
encore plus grande est encore plus
étrange en dimensions 1 milliard tout
point d'une hyper planète de rayons un
kilomètre est à seulement quelques
centimètres de l'hyper équateur les
inégalités issues périmétrique dit même
plus que cela
elle dit que si on prend n'importe quel
sous-ensemble de l'hyper planète
représentant un volume plus de sa moitié
alors tous les points de la planète sont
incroyablement près de ce sous-ensemble
plus précisément la probabilité d'être
loin de ce sous-ensemble des croît
exponentiellement vite vers zéro dès que
l'on cherche à s'éloigner d'une distance
de plus de r sur racine 2d ou air et le
rayon de l'hyper planète
bref ce qui peut retenir de tout ça
c'est que espace de très grandes
dimensions sont hyper bizarre pour
commencer la notion de distance celle
qui définit typiquement l'hyper boulet
l'hyper sphère est extrêmement contre
intuitive et finalement assez peu utile
en particulier
l'algorithme du plus proche voisin est
complètement inutile dans ce genre d'
espaces mais aussi cette analyse montre
que toute petite erreur dans
l'apprentissage des structures
géométriques de grandes dimensions peut
conduire à beaucoup d'instabilité en
effet l'inégalité iso périmétrique
implique que même si l'on parvient à
identifier 99% d'une structure
géométrique com
ni perse faire de rayon air en
dimensions des pour tous points bien
identifiés de la structure géométrique
il existera une petite perturbation de
taille environ air / racine carrée 2d
qui conduisent un point de la structure
qui soit mal identifiées par
l'algorithme de machine learning
autrement dit l'apprentissage de
nombreuses structures géométriques de
grandes dimensions ne peut pas être
robuste à moins d'être parfait ne pourra
pas être robuste à des perturbations
pourtant infime des données c'est ce
qu'on appelle typiquement le phénomène
du wan pixels attaque connaît le
meilleur réseau de neurones
d'aujourd'hui en général 99% du temps
si vous lui montrez une l'image de chat
il pourra reconnaître qu'il s'agit en
effet d'un chat mais bizarrement il sera
généralement possible de légèrement
modifié la valeur d'un pixel pour que le
réseau de neurones deviennent tout à
coup incapable de reconnaître le chat
une petite perturbation de la donne et
modifie complètement le comportement du
réseau de neurones bref en grande
dimension même un super machine learning
risque fort de voir des illusions et
d'apprendre des sortes de superstition
ou plutôt devrais je dire d'hypers
tition un énorme merci à elle gît qui
tient une chaîne qui est absolument
magnifique mais c'est vraiment
absolument génial en termes d'élégance
mathématiques que c'est vraiment ce qui
se fait de mieux dans le youtube
francophone on va voir des vidéos par
l'élégance des mathématiques ressort rit
danse et vidéo
c'est pas toujours très facile à
comprendre mais ce n'est pas plus
difficile à comprendre qu'une vidéo
cette forme donc si vous aimez le style
de vidéos que je fais allez voir
vraiment éligible ou fait des trucs sur
l'hypothèse de riemann par exemple
qu'une excellente vidéo
mon corps je vous recommande vivement la
vidéo dodji sur le thème de banat retard
ski et puis aussi toutes ces vidéos et
des trucs moins connus mais qui sont
tout aussi fabuleux et élégant comme par
exemple le théorème de bisous ou encore
sa vidéo sur new rose tout ça c'est des
trucs vraiment tellement élégant
c'est vraiment l'élégance mathématiques
comme on les aime l'énergie en a parlé
de régularisation et de robustesse qui
fait pas mal de notions dans la vidéo
précédente
est difficile à suivre je m'excuse
encore une fois de faire des vidéos un
peu trop compliqué en ce moment là c'est
pas facile ça va être encore un peu
comme ça pour deux ou trois vidéos
encore et après on abordera des notions
notamment sur un moral d ia qui sont les
conséquences sociétales de
l'intelligence artificielle qui seront
beaucoup plus accessible est beaucoup
plus facile à comprendre dernière fois
que vous avez aussi poser un problème de
facteurs de conclusion il fallait s'y de
déterminer comment c'était possible que
entre les blancs et les noirs
en fait il y avait le même taux de
sentence de condamnation à mort lors des
procès pour homicide et vous avez été
très imaginatif encore une fois en
proposant pas mal d'idées notamment
peut-être que pour qu'un noir en arrive
à un procès peut-être qu'il ya besoin de
moins d'éléments à conviction et que du
coup les noirs qui se présente devant le
procès du coup sont a priori moins
coupables que les blancs
et pourtant malgré cela les noirs sont
condamnés autant que les blancs ça sera
une explication de comment est ce qu'on
peut avoir du racisme tout en ayant des
chiffres qui ont l'air d'indiquer qu'il
n'y a pas de racisme
une autre explication très pertinent ce
qui a été proposé le fait que peut-être
que les états où il ya pas mal de
condamnations à mort sont en fait des
états où il ya très peu de noirs du coup
en fait les états où il ya pas mal de
condamnations à mort sont des états
essentiellement où les blancs sont
condamnés à mort tout ça ce sont des
excellentes explication est absente une
part de vrai là-dedans faudrait regarder
un peu plus s'est donné pour but
comprendre mais ça me paraît loin d'être
farfelue ceci étant dit ce n'était pas à
l'explication avancée par la vidéo de
telles aides que voici que vous invite à
aller voir sur cette vidéo de telle aide
un énorme facteur de confusion est en
fait la couleur de peau de la victime
en effet les noirs ont tendance à tuer
plus des noir et blanc plus à tuer des
blancpain étrangement à couleur de peau
de victimes égale les noirs sont
beaucoup plus
souvent condamnés à mort que les blancs
vous invite à aller voir cette vidéo de
khaled pour plus d'informations enfin
pour tous ceux qui attendent
impatiemment des vidéos sur le bail à
nice mme bah ça viendra mais c'est pas
pour tout de suite mais en attendant en
fait il ya déjà du matériel sur youtube
où je parle de baïse à nice mme
notamment les vidéos d'axiome du podcast
que je tiens avec thibaut de la chaîne
mais sophie et notamment dans le dernier
podcast axium on a pas mal parlé de
certains éléments fondamentaux du bail à
nice notamment cette idée d'à priori je
vous propose donc passé un petit extrait
ici et s'il veut en savoir plus bas à
les voir l'épisode de taxi homme neuf
qui s'appelle perception bnl tu es un
système si davantage sur le le côté le
problème des a priori parce que c'est ce
qu'on se demander mon sert très cool
cette idée de base à nice mais pourquoi
est-ce que du pôle et c'est pas plus
défendu gros problème et a priori
effectivement c'est que ça exprès c'est
quoi le sens tu as une proposition dans
la charmante sans lui parler et à un a
priori cette proposition ça paraît
presque absurde a envie de dire bah j'ai
pas regardé les données puis la torah tu
pourras dire grognon et en fait non
c'est vraiment pas faire ça fait
vraiment partie des grands sites pas
déjà un a priori dessus il faut que ces
prises a priori sont vraiment s'est
passé vraiment le côté très très
controversé et très très difficile à
accepter du business et c'est le fait
qu'il faut absolument toujours avoir un
a priori quel que soit le sujet même si
on n'y a jamais pensé que c'est assez
étrange et troublant
depuis ma mort je peux par exemple on
parlait le toit avec sébastien vergé qui
comparent exactement peut-être vous
parlez des témoins deux boxeurs surtout
boxer un autre sujet je sais plus quel
et normand il dit c'est le sien dit je
sais pas qui menait une phrase assez
classique et du coup je le poussais
avoir un avis parce que pour devenir dit
mais c'est arrivé à paris comme teralys
même si tu as beaucoup d'incertitudes
sur thèse cet avis là il faut décrire se
sont étendues sur mon ignorance et tout
ça mais il faut avoir faut quand même
avoir un a priori et
même si on n'est pas du tout sûr de
celle d'à priori il faut quand même en
avoir un a priori celle c'est assez
c'est assez troublant est difficile veut
pas dire encourager les gens à avoir un
avis sur tout et n'importe quoi il
défend de façon ultra tranché c'est
juste il faut admettre que c'est pas
égales en fait que tape ou à la limite
que ça c'est vraiment une position dit
non vraiment je pense qu'il ya autant de
chances que ah que non a dans ce cas ok
t'as un a priori c'est ça tu attends on
veut servir ok donc ton a priori c'est
un sur deux mais très souvent fait c'est
pas le cas si tu réfléchis bien si je
suis pas là par rapport à cette
proposition là certes mais un pistolet
sur la tempe et si tu te trompes on tire
tu vas pas tiré une pièce at it be your
face pour décider tu vas chercher à
faire le meilleur pari est souvent il ya
quand même un truc qui va pencher d'un
côté donc c'est très important dans
d'autres sources ont figuré avec un
pistolet sur la tempe
ouais après c'est pas parce que la
lumière puisse elle est la plus calme ce
raid de poey sont à priori oui parce que
les gens ils te disent ce jour je sais
pas j'ai pas la vexer même s'il ya des
tas de sujets sur lesquels les gens sur
des avis sur tout mais sur plein de
sujets ils ont pas la vie et c'est
énervant parce que c'est pas vrai on a
on havre à cause d un avis on sait que
ce n'est pas le côté des défend la vie
de façon un peu stupide et bornés c'est
vraiment simplement voilà on a une
intuition hâtivement signe des choses
qu'on va croire des choses qu'on va pas
croire et c'est très important parce que
c'est sur ça que se bâtit la
connaissance hier et edgar donc même en
mathématiques et en mathématiques
souvent enfin bon moi j'aime bien paris
en mathématiques sur les questions que
je sais pas dire l'air et je pense que
c'est une réaction assez classique des
chercheurs qui surtout que quand il
commence à connaître un sujet et se
disent bon bah voilà cette conjecture je
pense que c'est vrai où je pense que va
falloir changer un petit truc et
peut-être que ça va faire passer que et
je pense que le l'un des gros problèmes
en fait mon éducation mathématiques
c'est que on ne cherche pas avoir d'à
priori sur les mathématiques peut-être
parce que les mathématiques sont c'est
une façon un peu autoritaire du coup on
se contente juste de prendre
l'information mais ouais c'est je trouve
que c'est très important et très très
intéressant et très stimulant d'essayer
de se poser une question a priori avant
de répondre à la question
de dire d'abord une intuition de travail
et l'intuition et six mois c'est un bon
point de départ poursuit ensuite de
développer le réseau lance donc une
espèce de du gouffre entre la rigueur
mathématique quant à une démonstration
ou là vraiment une argumentation solide
à la composition puis quand tu effaces
juste à une proposition ça juste une
vague intuition est ce que c'est vrai il
faut aussi comprendre c'est pas
totalement un a priori c'est un a priori
purge pas comment dire il n'y a pas de
propositions qui sont tellement
abstraite et détaché totalement de
toutes tes autres connaissances que
vraiment ce soit purement me faro
voilà une sorte de propositions a tout à
voir traîner un site unique à ce que tu
crois en la vraiment l impression mais
j'ai envie dire même là tu pourrais dire
que j'en sais rien ainsi on sait pas si
c'est si vrai dire parce que ça voudrait
dire quoi si je prends une proposition
au hasard dans un langage la plupart des
propositions sont fausses donc de lui
dans ce cas j'aurais plutôt parié sur
fait que c'est faux mais moi aussi je te
donne une proposition ça en général dit
plus de choses dont on essaye de dire
plus des choses vraies que fausses enfin
bref
non mais cette question de la priory à
l'est vraiment elle est vraiment
intéressante
j'espère que j'avais mais cette vidéo la
notion de dimension est en fait assez
crucial en maquillant remis au parlement
du fléau de la dimensionnalité et dans
le prochain épisode on parlera comment
combattre parce que claude à
dimensionnalité en essayant de réduire
la dimension des objets d'étude du
machine learning notamment avec des
techniques comme la cpu ou svd on verra
ce que ça veut dire la semaine prochaine
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas vous
que les futurs épisodes nord ce type
heures power dont et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois on peut
fabriquer des fleurs de vienne avec deux
pétales avec 3 ou même avec 5
pourquoi ça ne marcherait pas avec
davantage on dit alors que ces
diagrammes sont symétriques chaque
pétale se déduit des autres à partir
d'une même rotation il existe d'ailleurs
des diagrammes symétrique à sept pétales
comme par exemple celui obtenu à partir
de cet ensemble l'a répété cette fois
par rotation ce sont ces diagrammes là
les symétries qui sont à mon humble avis
les plus bas
[Musique]